when the History Channel decided to base
a series around people cutting down
trees none of us could have imagined the
colorful characters that introduced to
the world the excitement doesn't end
when the Axman cameras stop rolling
either here are just a few things the
show's producers didn't catch on film
Jimmy Smith's illegal Salvage back in
2009 S&S aqua logging got into some hot
water with the Department of Natural
Resources for illegally salvaging wood
from a river as sunken logs become an
integral part of a riverbed removing
them can cause a lot of damage to the
ecosystem DNR officers became suspicious
of S&S after seeing them do some shady
stuff on an episode of ax men so for
future reference committing a crime on
TV is a really bad idea to prevent
further harm
dNR officials seized over two dozen logs
from S&S unfortunately for company owner
Jimmy Smith this wasn't the end of his
troubles disability fraud in addition to
stealing wood Jimmy Smith allegedly
built more than $50,000 in fraudulent
disability benefits during the time
Smith salvaged the timber in question he
was also collecting medical benefits for
two claims he filed with the Department
of Labor and industries one from 1993
and another from 1996 according to a
surgeon Smith had complained of
impairments in his shoulders neck back
or any other portions of the extremities
in other words things that would prevent
him from cutting and moving large pieces
of wood and equipment as he was seen
doing on television his trouble with the
law didn't last much longer though after
pleading guilty to the fraud allegations
in 2011 Smith passed away in 2012
Kaitlyn Sims illness while some loggers
have been accused of cashing in on
injuries they don't have Kaitlyn Sims is
the exact opposite the young logger has
battled cystic fibrosis a terminal
illness since she was four she didn't
let that stop her from felling and
moving trees however making some of them
may
ell counterparts look like wimps in the
process to fight the disease's effects
Sims undergoes regular treatments
allowing her to keep active and continue
working increasing her odds of survival
Sims also uses her fame to help spread
CF awareness my name is Caitlin films
unless cystic fibrosis advocate and I'm
a student at San affair college this is
one tough lady death of a logger
blogging is dangerous work and some of
ax men starves have sadly lost their
lives on the job
helicopter logger but Colin toois no
died in 2013 while attempting to airlift
some lumber in Oregon according to
witnesses a rotor came off his chopper
which then flipped upside down the
incident prompted a lengthy
investigation mike pihl's arrest logging
seems to attract unusual personalities
such is the case with Mike Pihl owner of
the aptly named Mike Pihl logging in
2009 Pihl got into an alcohol induced
fender bender and flipped his Jeep
injuring three of his kids since the
incident occurred on private property
the police filed no DUI charges but they
did charge pal with felony assault
fortunately Pihl hasn't been in any
trouble since Roger
Gunter's poaching master diver Roger
Gunter has been caught six times for
hunting without a license before he
gained fame on ax men Gunter was already
a well-known Florida monkey Fischer for
the uninitiated monkey fishing refers to
fishing using electricity not fishing
for actual monkeys he was caught six
times over a 30 to 40 year span but
since then Gunter has apparently mended
his ways even befriended the local
authorities with whom he once butted
heads it's a really unlikely friendship
considering Bob spent his career not
trying to catch fish but trying to catch
Roger
well I don't chase him anymore and he
doesn't run from me shelby stanga's
arrest in October 2014 Shelby Swamp man
Stanga was picked up by the police for
cutting down his neighbor
trade well that might not sound like a
big deal remember
it does count as destruction of private
property vandalism or both curiously the
cutting took place three years before
the actual arrest
apparently trees have some busy
protectors down there in the bayou a
matter of fact our swamp authenticity
questions like most reality shows axemen
has to deal with the accusations of
inauthenticity many from people who work
within the logging industry according to
some real-life loggers like veteran
bills sword axe men presents an overly
dramatic picture that's pretty far from
the truth sword told The Oregonian those
producers drum up a bunch of baloney to
make it dramatic
hmm you be the judge thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know what you think of ax men